you know here in las vegas and southern
nevada we've got some of the hottest
temperatures right now for
the entire country this heat wave is
happening and it's a little early in the
year
for these kinds of temperatures bianca
holman explains how
cars can be one of the deadliest places
for pets and babies
in a matter of minutes bianca good
morning
hey good morning sherry so you know
cooling stations like this one behind me
are open all across the valley
but not only can it be deadly outdoors
it can also be deadly
inside vehicles even if you have tent or
leave the car
running so local firefighters say that
you should never leave children the
elderly or pets inside a vehicle
if the motor is running the car could be
stolen if the motor is off
the car can reach deadly temperatures in
five minutes officials say if you see a
person or pet inside a car and you're
obligated by law to call 9-1-1
you should stay on the scene and help
guide the first responders to the
vehicle
just consider a medical emergency in the
city of las vegas
police and will fire will respond lights
and sirens
to the incident because we need to get
there as quickly as possible
and also you may not know this a child's
body heats up three to five times
faster than an adult does and so that's
why just cracking the window
isn't enough avoid the deadly
temperatures put your cell phone
in or bag or purse in the back seat
don't be remembered to look in the back
to see your child
or your pet and of course again like we
said the cooling
stations are open across the valley
we've got a complete list on our website
at 8newsnow.com
bianca holman 8 news now